and speaking of budgets recently when
Donald Trump announced his new budget
2019 budget he decided that we don't
really need an environment I guess we
don't need to track things like climate
change we don't need to be fully aware
of how bad corporations are destroying
the planet
so in Donald Trump's 2019 budget the
there's some cuts here so let's see
let's see what what he wants to cut we
have a sixteen point five million
dollars in funding cut from the overall
EPA budget forty eight jobs lost at the
global chair climate change research
program
he has zeroed out sixty six million for
the atmospheric protection program
another 103 million cut from the a PP
it's gonna eliminate the science to
achieve results program which provides
twenty eight million in research grants
and academic fellowships and intervine
in environmental science and engineering
ninety nine million dollar cut at the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration we're cutting all of
these programs designed to protect the
planet or at the very least give us
information about how badly we're
destroying the planet he wants to cut
the budgets for those that is what is in
his 2019 budget that just recently came
out at the same time a few pages later
the Trump administration lays out their
energy plan which to no one's surprise
calls for more cuts to renewable energy
programs while expanding funding for oil
gas and coal so not only is Donald Trump
slashing millions of dollars from
environmental protection and
climate change study but he's also
cutting funding for renewable energy and
giving more money to the dying fossil
fuel companies in the United States the
renewable energy sector has been one of
the fastest growing industries in the
United States for several years now and
he wants to destroy that because he
wants to repay the exons the shells the
Texaco is the bps the the coal companies
the fracking industry he wants all of
those guys to have more money even
though the rest of the world is acting
like grown-ups right now and saying we
understand the link between burning
fossil fuels and climate change so we're
gonna start investing more in renewable
we're gonna push renewable projects our
goal is to have our city our state our
country renewable energy only in the
next ten years and yet here we are in
the United States
billions upon billions upon billions of
dollars to individual defense
contractors but we've got to cut back on
satellites that track carbon emissions
in the atmosphere by NASA that's another
one of the cuts in this stupid budget
put forth by Donald Trump he doesn't
even want to track carbon in the
atmosphere because why that's gonna make
life pretty tough for those fossil fuel
companies who continue to fund
Republican campaigns and god forbid that
those big Republican donors have to
clean up the mess that they created by
destroying our planet but that's the
reality in which we live in today thank
you for watching today I appreciate
David letting me sit in I'll be back
tomorrow I am fairing cousins from Ring
of Fire and you've been watching the
David Pakman show